it's kind of like Dancing with the Stars
for uh legit actors when you're going on
there you know you're on the back nine
of life now if you're like if Fighters
are doing the slap Fight League bro you
that's where I'm like oh bro this is
Dancing with the Stars for Fighters if
you're in slap Fight League it's not
good hey I disagree I think I think Kim
Sylvia is perfect for a slap fight I
think he's I think he's more set for
that than for anything else on this plot
I saw Bigfoot silver Bigfoot Silva once
he involved the slap Fight League I'm
like who the hell is going to take a
slap from Bigfoot Silva now if you if I
would only do it if I get the first slap
because you know he's a little chinny
but if he gets to slap you first he's
going undefeated